well join me in the studio socialist and
author Grace Blakely and YouTube
commentator Paul Davis uh both I would
imagine identifying as provocateurs of
course
talk about this first of all Paul I I
just find the whole personal pronoun
thing honestly absurd my personal
pronouns on my Twitter biography are now
uh hot hotter hottest and I frankly if
people don't call me those then they
have to be jailed I go along with that
but I did that to highlight that when I
do that and say that people then accuse
me of being ridiculous I think the whole
thing is ridiculous why do we need
personal pronouns we don't need personal
pronouns I honestly I don't think it's
kind to allow people to live in delusion
at the end of the day at the end of the
day at the end of the day
and a woman is okay just because you
dress like a woman talk like a woman act
like a woman it does not make you a
woman and I am so tired of us allowing
these people to let us live in delusion
it is delusional to think you are the
opposite gender and it is not kind I
can't even go on I love flying British
Airways right my preferred daylight a
wonderful Airline
and they always used to it would also be
a lovely Posh voice saying good
afternoon ladies and gentlemen welcome
to pretty and I used to felt soothing
particularly if I came from another
country back to Britain I felt
immediately at ease my captain was there
sounding like he was you know from some
wonderful pathy News Bulletin and he
referred to us as ladies and gentlemen
that's now been banned they're not
allowed to say ladies and gentlemen
because there might be one person on the
plane who says oh whoa whoa hang on I
don't identify as a lady or a gentleman
well okay fine I don't care but I do so
where's my right to be called a
gentleman here's Grace know how I feel
up with this I'm so so bored of it all
I'm so bored of the fact that this is
the one item that's constantly coming up
over and over and over again and you can
completely see why right conservative
governments have destroyed our economy
we're in the middle of a massive climate
crisis just some of the hottest week
ever I've just come over from Europe
it's extremely hot and instead of
talking about that we spend hours and
hours and hours talking about pronouns
talking about going into bathrooms
talking about you know all of this stuff
that just doesn't matter it doesn't
matter
it doesn't matter to you so boring
doesn't matter to you but it does matter
to women in sport it does matter to
women whose young daughters might be
using these dressings it doesn't matter
to the victims of male rapists who see
their attackers identify as women get
into women's prisons sorry so when you
say they don't matter they really do
matter you have those issues aired in
the appropriate you know spaces we are
in you know in sports have that
discussion amongst people but like
literally it's about priorities isn't it
there's a certain number of times we
have on these shows to discuss the
issues
you don't think women's before we come
to our I don't think women's sport
matters as much as climate change I
think like it's women's equality in
which we can play sports women's
equality I know that that could be
probably absolutely quality Humanity
well I mean yeah of course but actually
I mean the whole point that I was going
to make on this segment actually is that
like you cannot separate feminism from
class issues like if you're just going
around saying like I don't know
um I think the female CEO of a weapons
manufacturer should be paid the same as
a male CEO and that's the hill I'm gonna
die on I'm not fighting that fight with
you because ultimately like what I care
about are the struggles that ordinary
women face every day well let's come to
the the main point of the segment which
is this issue of women's rights to be
paid the same as men in sport now the
Australian women's football team have
criticized the pay Gap in the upcoming
World Cup prize money just take a look
at what they said as a team
736 footballers had the honor of
representing their country on the
world's biggest stage this tournament
yeah many are still denied the basic
rights to organize and collectively
bargain collective bargaining has
allowed us to ensure we now get the same
conditions as the socceroos with one
exception FIFA will still only offer
women one quarter as much prize money as
men for the same achievement
well okay this is an interesting part
because if you look at the revenue for
example in 2019 FIFA generated uh 586
million pounds in total revenue the
men's uh for the 19 2019-22 cycle 5.8
billion uh record Revenue through the
men's World Cup so the women's game has
come on in Leaps and Bounds the English
lionesses fantastic win sellout crowds
they're making a lot more money they're
definitely way way further now towards
whether men are commercially than they
were but they're still a way off and
when you saw at Wimbledon for example
the men's final was watched by three
times as many people and yet they were
both free to wear on the BBC you could
watch both if you wanted to so there was
three times as much interest in the
men's game they played two sets more per
match than the women doing it the women
get equal pay I'm not quite sure why I
don't think it's a matter of equality
it's just a matter of fairness isn't it
yeah well I I won I think all of the
women should thank the men for fun
ending our leagues because most of our
leagues would not exist without the men
number one number two when we have the
same numbers then we should get the same
pay I'm sorry I play I play volleyball
at the highest level and it's like when
we make what the men make and get the
crowds that the men draw then we should
get paid the same why why is it actually
a fight for equality Grace I mean why if
if women in a particular sport for
example turned out to generate more
Revenue right because they were more
watchable and in America the women's
football team is better than the men and
they do generate even a school level far
more interest from girls than boys for
example I don't see why equality should
be the aim why shouldn't they get paid
more than the men well look I mean there
are all sorts of problems with the way
that this market for labor is basically
a market for labor works like I
personally don't think that the top
football players in the world should be
paid as much as they do I think it's
ridiculous the amount that's marketing
exactly it's Market forces that be the
way that we decide you know who's to
generate what who generates more
personally I'm very much in favor of the
fact that they came out there and said
collective bargaining ultimately like at
the average worker in this country
hasn't had a pay rise in over a decade
how is that going to change that's going
to change when they organize with one
another I'm tired of women whining their
names the men literally the men fund our
leagues and we will still whine that we
don't get paid enough and honestly when
athletes do like this it makes all
of us look bad because instead of being
thankful for the league that we have we
go out and whine and complain about the
pay I mean as I said I'm not whining you
sound like you're maybe doing a bit of
whining but like personally I don't
think we should be whining I think
people should be organized
join a union get out there and fight for
it should the women footballers get the
same as the men yeah I think it probably
makes sense even if anything like the
revenue ultimately like it's not gonna
change it's not going to change unless
they organize that's actually true
across every sector
let me ask you this it on Talent alone
for example as a yardstick the U.S
women's football team were beaten by a
group of under 15 boys from Texas right
who were very good under 15 boys but
they're under 15 boys team beat them I
think about eight nine nil or something
so why should women footballers who are
clearly nowhere near as good as their
male counterparts just technically why
should they get paid anything like as
much money well I mean you know it sucks
doesn't it that like as
you're you play volleyball I'm a surfer
I
assur thing it's very hard for women to
build up a body strength this is
something that I've learned that very
much the hard way and so yeah there is
there is equal pay yeah there is and
actually you know it it's one of those
Sports where can a woman be as good as a
man well it's different it's a different
sport really it's not you know it is the
same sport but it's very different
watching a woman surf than is watching
Amanda because you know the average male
body is different from the average woman
like uh woman's body for all this but is
there any actual technical reason why a
woman can't do with a circle what a man
can do yeah there's I mean there's loads
of reasons like it is about the upper
body strength it's about like the way
that the body is built should women
Surfers at the elite level get the same
as well like again I think it's it just
is different like it's a different kind
of game and people watch it oh you're
shaking your head no I just think when
we start making the same amount of money
as the man then we should get paid the
same as the man I don't hear the man
whining about only fans models getting
paid more than them I don't hear the men
whining about models getting paid more
than that Kendall Jenner is the highest
paid supermodel where are the male super
models however men dominating an
industry women will just complain I mean
I don't know if that's true about any
fans because there are a lot of men on
only fans as well but I mean look the
main point I think they make the same I
have no idea but like if maybe if you
averaged out the number of men and women
that are on that website anyway look the
main point here the point that I came on
it I wanted to make was the um the like
the problem that we have in in our
economy at the moment is not that like
the average football player isn't played
the same as the average man it is
probably an injustice and I'm glad that
they're organizing and working together
to fight for that but ultimately the
problem we have in our economy is that
nobody's getting paid enough money
because inflation's eroded people's
wages even before that no one had a pay
rise in a really long time and the
lesson from this is as I've said I'm
going to say it again because it's
important lesson and no one knows about
them anymore because they see them as a
hangover from 1970s join a union because
otherwise your boss is gonna well there
are unions for all these they're all
it's the unions that are fighting for
them exactly but on okay but just as a
general point though
the principle you think that women
should get paid the same even if they're
not as technically as good and not
producing as much revenue objective
judgment isn't it on whether or not
they're like technically
Let me Give an example an example would
be the Olympics if you made it
non-gender specific how many women would
win medals well I mean no okay it may be
in a question maybe in shooting I think
again there's no sense that the men
might win you can say like oh you know
this group is better than this group but
again I think it's different men are
let's not
illusion and in most cases
more people men and women want to watch
men play sport correct that's just a
demonstrable fact that may change now my
point is if it changes I don't see why
equality should be the only ambition for
the women if it turns out that in some
sport women get more viewers watching
and therefore draw more Revenue I'm all
for them getting more money than the man
can you name five WNBA players five
female soccer players I mean I can't
name any soccer players
we would get equal pay if we would just
get the support from the family well let
me let me tell you name five let me tell
you
what the WNBA is we need our support
you're asking the wrong person yeah you
really are um but I do want to mention
one thing which is I had Dale Vince on
the program he's this uh he's been
funding just stop oil and also he was
very very keen to show his feminist
credentials because he just he owns a
football team and he had just hired the
first female manager uh football team
but there was a slight problem which he
only made of the caretaker and I saw a
potential flaw here so let's see what
went down when I interviewed him
you didn't think by pointing the first
female caretaker manager of a
professional men's team you would get
any attention
she's the best candidate for the job at
the club this is what happens you look
at within the club you find your best
coach and you say take the team in an
interim period while we do a proper
recruitment process that's all that's
happening here how do you keep coming
back to that
of appointments she's only a caretaker
look at our record so if you believed
him that much you'd have been a manager
you've got all the publicity but
actually she's not got the full result
yeah it works and I suspect what's going
to happen is you're going to go fast in
football you're going to probably go and
find a bloke to replace it and then
you're going to have to deal with that I
I thought you understood football piss I
do I'm an awesome thing
well you might be massively unsurprised
to learn that 12 Days Later
Anna Dinkley has been removed from her
job as caretaker manager and replaced by
a man
yeah Dale talk to good game on feminism
and women's rights and posted about it
and got all the publicity and in the end
he got rid of her after 12 days and put
a bloke in charge and you can make your
own view about Mr Vince for doing that
uh lovely to see you both thank you both
very much indeed